si le groupe Wagner a toujours été dans
le collimateur de la Maison Blanche du
Pentagone évidemment des services de
renseignement américain la tonalité
employée cette fois à l'encontre du
groupe n'avait jamais été aussi
virulente de la part de la Maison
Blanche en tout cas or ce jeudi John
Kirby qui s'exprime pour le président
dans le domaine de la politique
étrangère et de la sécurité nationale on
le rappelle a clairement livré à la
presse une somme de constat qu'il juge
préoccupant d'abord la Maison Blanche
dénonce l'explosion des effectifs de
Wagner en Ukraine autour de 50000 hommes
selon le renseignement américain dont 10
000 soldats aguerris généralement
anciens des forces régulières russes
mais qui encadre près de 40000
mercenaires arrachés aux prisons russes
lors des dernières campagnes de
recrutement une véritable chair à canon
selon le Pentagone et un groupe Wagner
qui essuie en ce moment même des pertes
considérables notamment sur le front de
batmouth ce qui préoccupe davantage
encore la Maison Blanche de soutien
accordé à cette compagnie Privée qui
échappe donc au dialogue entre État et
au soutien qui vient de Corée du Nord
sous la forme d'équipements et de
munitions en grande quantité toujours
selon John Kirby Wagner devient en
réalité l’armée privée de Vladimir
Poutine une armée qui jusqu'à présent
lui obéit au doigt et à l'oeil notamment
pour accomplir ses volontés en Ukraine
mais également et cela n'a pas échappé à
la diplomatie américaine une sorte de
garde pretorienne qui garantit la
sécurité du président russe à
l'intérieur même de la Russie et
notamment contre toute velléité de
remettre en cause son autorité et ses
choix stratégiques bien qu'il soit
encore trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions fermes plusieurs analystes
ici à Washington lisent cela à la fois
comme la démonstration de la fébrilité
de Vladimir Poutine mais également comme
la quasi garantie que son autorité ne
soit jamais remise en cause par une
quelconque forme de rivalité politique à
l'intérieur de la Russie